information and then like you keep
contradicting yourself and I think the
reason is is because I am a clash of
cultures so I am very you know obviously
I'm Bangladeshi British Muslim and I
think the modern side is what is me what
I'm fighting against does that make
sense so the more I'm realizing actually
I'm not this model woman is the more
comfortable I'm getting in who I am I
don't I don't think you can really go
back like I I don't think you can really
claim traditional if you're separated
from your like your husband it's no when
I say traditional I say traditionally my
values in my morals not that I'm I'm I'm
gonna stick in a marriage that I'm
unhappy in because I'm a traditional
woman it's more I know what I want for
myself and I know that this right but
like that rhetoric right there that
sounds very modern well can I just say
again all I'm hearing is I I I I I I I'm
not and I'm not trying to personalize it
to you it's just that you're speaking
and a lot of the things that have been
said today are eye base and in
relationships in marriage it's about
partnership working together and we're
not nobody's perfect sometimes sometimes
you make mistakes and you have to work
through it and we've I'm not married
I've never been married and I think it's
easy for me to talk on it you know from
my perspective but when you've got
a child involved your feelings involved
you know finances involved whatever it
might be work involved your friends
involved
you you have to kind of peel back on all
of the factors that influence you and
look at the bare bones of the
relationship which is you your child and
your partner and literally Zone in on
that and make that your priority wait
I've got a question I've got a question
quickly just a kind of caveat of it yeah
yeah so on that note because you're
talking about I I do would you say that
the Modern Woman is selfish then yes
because it because society allows that
to be the case because it's about what
you want or is it what the woman wants
that's the case
because I've been very selfless in
relationships I've got nothing back
right exactly yeah but so but yeah no no
no but it's very involved you kind of
have to be selfish I started to cut you
off yeah that's all right selfish like
how though
when kids involved well like your kids
are your priorities so it's like
regardless of what how anybody feels
like your child is your priority isn't
it in that relationship with two parents
my priority is to take care of my child
yeah is but that's that's being selfless
like when you have a kid it's not
supposed to be about you anymore it's
about your kid [__] your happiness but
that's exactly unless you're in like
extenuating circumstances where you are
getting abused or yeah I'm with you I'm
with you
if your child's in danger yeah I I agree
yeah but that's not that's not the
majority of cases if it's the child's
side danger you need to try work out too
but that's exactly what like for example
my daughter doesn't know we're separate
my daughter hasn't experienced anything
different when she sees us she sees us
very amicable and she she doesn't know
anything different
no we don't live in the same house okay
but when I say that when I say I'm
putting my daughter first that's the
reason why I'm not chasing another man
or chasing another relationship because
the most beneficial one is me and her
father right like see you keep kind of
contradicting yourself and you did it
again just here there because you said
your daughter you don't live in the same
house but your daughter doesn't know
anything's up yeah she may not at five
but she will bill yeah and when and so
and so she might not understand it but
you you can't say that it's like she's
not going to notice that her dad or her
mom isn't in the home no but I'm not
saying there's my my dad used to work
here while my family were back home my
dad wasn't present in their lives every
single day and I think that's another
big misconception that a parent or a dad
has to be at home every single day it's
a cultural thing is that did it affect
you and not having him there all the
time no no not at all and I love my dad
like my dad was an amazing man an
amazing father figure amazing that's why
I can't trash men because I have so much
respect for mine I don't think it would
have been better if your dad was there a
bit often you spent more time
I'm just thinking about Pearl nothing
was that no no yeah my dad my dad was
gone my dad was gone a lot too and I'd
say like it did affect me like I yeah I
mean I would have been better if he was
there I still love him and I respect him
more than anything but like I I think it
would be dumb to say I didn't want my
dad around more
do you think he would have changed your
perspective on
being traditional Western do you think
if your dad was there more that you'd be
a lot more traditional than Western
well I think the problem with me was
when I went to UNI and I came out of my
traditional or my culture bubble the
bubble so I think that bubble protected
me for so long and I wish I stayed in it
a bit longer because the trauma only
came when I thought oh let me experience
a bit now can I just say this do you
think your dad being present in your
life when you were growing up would help
you manage your situation right now with
your husband better because he would
have been able to advise you or even now
I don't know what your relationship is
at now but he would be able to guide you
or even have an impact on you in a way
that would allow you to manage the
situation better
I feel like I'm managing the situation
well compared to what Society will tell
me because there's a lot of people that
will tell me why are you even investing
any more time or why even allowing this
Dynamics because a lot of people say OH
Close book and rush out yeah that's why
girls give the worst advice yeah I don't
I don't say you're managing it well
unless you're still with him can I just
no it's like it's it's not you can't
it's like that's like that's like that's
like like failing a test and saying you
guys no when I say managing it well I'm
saying about I'm respecting his values
or views in where he is in life I'm
respecting that he's not ready to commit
to the marriage and children yet because
he feels like he can't be that
responsible
so right I'm so proud of you like we can
all see how much like you love your
daughter how much you're trying to make
this work like because life is hard you
know like no no no no no
she only got here she only got here
because she did she because before we
said yeah that ah women women said they
lack the truth in it your husband told
you the truth saying that I may
potentially want to step out on you yeah
and that's what started this whole
debacle of problems of relationship so
him being honest is kind of why you're
here isn't it initially it was the my ex
cheating that was the issue but you said
you had help for that trauma you said
you had that trauma no no that's
something I've gone in later like would
you say within the last year because it
seems to me like you and your husband
split because of something that he might
do in the future yeah and that was me
looking back at myself saying I was the
fault of that and that was me taking it
are you now saying that as a young woman
that traditional is the way to go 100
thank you a hundred percent I'm I will I
Believe In traditional roles I believe I
just believe that this Society doesn't
enable that and a lot of my anger as
well even in my relationship was the
fact that I had to work and I had to do
things that a woman shouldn't
necessarily do because Society now is
too expensive can I just say that to
this Society though can I just say that
traditional women always work they did
yeah
no no no no you asked your mama how she
worked just because she didn't leave the
house yeah exactly so we're doing the
housework and then more she's talking
about career I'm talking about Korea
well I'm saying that it all depends on
how you see it no 100 right and also if
you and your husband
wouldn't it be better if you both got a
flat with three bedrooms and worked out
two separately that's the thing money is
the issue so if money wasn't an issue of
course we could have a mansion and we
could no I'm just saying is it is it
there a sliver part than to live
together
yeah uh yes
we would
it's just easier for now because
obviously where we're not fine I'm not
easier I'm talking about cheaper is it
cheaper to live separately or is it
would it be cheaper to live together
it's just not a position we're at now
because we're only I've only just healed
could you just answer that yes or no is
it cheaper to live apart
it's cheaper to live together but
obviously if I'm not like I've only gone
through my counseling and are having to
learn about myself in the last year and
a half that time I was alone if that
makes sense if I'd never done that I
would never have gone through counseling
or learn about myself and what and I've
learned and I think the thing is I had
an amazing father figure I had an
amazing childhood with my dad and my dad
not being there he was there you know
him not being there for parts isn't
impacted me at all my relationship was
amazing there was other things that
happened when I was a child that made it
more difficult
if that makes sense yeah in me in my
longer lifelong marriage and I think
once I then went counseling for that I
then realized actually there was a lot
of me that had to heal before I even
took that step can I just give you a bit
of advice as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible